When you left,
Mom passed away.
I got flipped back.
They rounded us to investigate
Earthbound Anomalies.
Monica? No.
How you feeling?
Like myself.
Now I can manipulate wavelengths
of the electromagnetic spectrum.
I'm very happy for you.
Where's the doctor? Yes, is.
Come on. Come
It gets pretty lonely out here.
I need to regain the memories
that the crate took for me.
I'll teach you.
You are Carol Danvers.
The most powerful person I knew
way before you
because you fired from the office.
I get in trouble for that.
I can see that about you.
But what happens when
I'm finally set free?
I'll be back before you know it.
Lieutenant, Trouble? Hi.
How do you have this?
My grandma sent it to me in the mail.
Have you ever wanted something so bad?
And it actually happened.
But it's not as great as you imagined it.
You want to save the world,
and you're going to save the world.
Well,
now don't go to tell me you stick around.
What is happening?
We switch places
whenever we use our powers.
Towns drop by.
Higher, further, faster.
Together.
Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie
This will be my brand new Marvels
Trailer video.
There's a bunch of Easter Eggs and
references, so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
This one focusing most
on their backstories and all the different
characters
explaining their new powers to each other.
Like,
what do they been doing this whole time?
First big one is Monica Rambeau,
explaining
basically the events of Wandavision
what happened with Scarlet Witch,
the Hex and her new mutant abilities
even though technically she's not
like an X-Men character, they mutated her
DNA, the hex mutated her DNA.
So thank you very much, Scarlet Witch.
Originally, most of us assumed
that they were going to call her Photon
because she had a couple of different
comic book names.
Like she is the original female version
of Captain Marvel, But supposedly
in the movie they'll also just be
calling her Captain Marvel.
Like in the movie.
They won't actually call her
the Photon character.
But there've been some toys in real life
that have called her
that totally out of context.
I have no idea how that's going to work.
It's a little bit confusing
for the most part.
I think they're just going to call her
Monica Rambeau.
Based on the way she explains her powers
to the other characters
in the last couple of trailers.
It seems like what they're going with
from the comics
because she has a bunch
of different powers in the comics.
she says she can see light, but
she can also redirect it in the comics,
the way that Captain Marvel absorbs
light in the way that Kamala Khan creates
these light constructs, kind of like
the Marvel version of Green Lantern,
basically, Monica Rambeau
can also become forms of light
in the comics, which is how she gets
super, super powerful.
part of the idea though
that in order to do that,
she has to be able
to understand how a form of energy works,
like a form of light energy.
Basically, a lot of people wondering
if she could absorb Infinity Stone energy
like a Thanos blaster.
But the full gotten technically, yes, but
she has to be able to understand exactly
how all the different Infinity Stones
work, which is incredibly complicated.
Like even most of the Avengers
didn't understand that.
So if she did understand it, Thanos
blast her with the infinity gantlet,
she would just turn into infinity
stone energy and become super powerful.
Otherwise she would just get vaporized
like anybody else
that got soaked with infinity
stone energy.
the main reason
why she was beefing with Captain Marvel
during the events of the One Division
series, though, is all because of her
leaving planet Earth.
Like this whole idea that Captain Marvel
has been gone this whole time.
People are wondering where she's gone.
It's been turned to this big meme.
but at least in present day, the older
Monica Rambeau after she got snapped back
by the Hulk's snap,
She was pissed at Captain Marvel,
thinking that she never came to help
take care of her mother
because she had cancer
and she died in the hospital.
She did not get snapped.
Her mother didn't get snapped.
supposedly
there's going to be a post-credits
scene, though,
because we have to tease the whole Kane
dynasty, the whole multiverse war plot
with other universes.
reportedly one of the post-credits
scenes will involve Monica Rambeau
making it to another universe
or getting trapped in another universe
somehow because of what's going on
with the two different bangles
and the weapon that the crew recreate.
there's some kind of incursion
like storyline where she gets trapped
or she gets stuck in another universe.
And in that other universe,
she winds up meeting a version
of her mother, Maria Rambeau,
who did become Captain Marvel
and thus survived the present day
in her younger state.
the closest example we have of
that is the 838 universe where Maria Rambeau
became Captain Marvel, like basically
the backstory of Captain Marvel,
But it was Marina Rambeau
who was piloting the ship
the day that they had the explosion
with the Tesseract energy.
the whole concept is meant to be a wink
back to the idea that Monica Rambeau
is the first female Captain Marvel
in the comics.
the other part of the trailer
here, too, is Ms..
Marvel explaining how she got her bangle
from her grandmother or her great
grandmother, how her mutant powers
worked in how the Bangles powers worked,
they didn't completely explain this
during the Ms..
Marvel episodes,
but the whole idea is that
she was a mutant
before she got the Bangles.
The bangle basically just activated her
x gene, her powers activated After that.
theoretically.
Her powers should work without the bangle.
It might be a little bit different.
We'll see how they explain this
during the course of the movie,
because we've never actually seen her
use her powers
without wearing the actual bangle.
But apart from her like, construct powers,
the whole idea is that every time
she uses the bangle because of the way
the two different bangles work.
This is quantum entanglement
idea where each of them switch places
because of the way their powers work.
then they have Captain Marvel explaining
what she's been doing so long and Chris
space away from Earth all these years.
Like everybody been wondering
what's been going
on, why you having come back to Earth
more often.
Moseley is trying to eradicate the Kree
who up to Avengers Infinity War Endgame,
they explain during Secret Invasion,
were busy eradicating the Skrull empire.
they basically decimated their homeworld.
The Skrull Homeworld
Sucralose The Skrull empire
took off to another planet
with his own sect of Skrulls.
And then Talos in the rest of the Skrulls
came to planet Earth.
Eventually, during the five year time
jump, that whole plot with the Skrulls
is going to lead up
to Captain America four.
That's more of like an Earth based plot.
So that's a little bit separate from
what's happening in the Marvel's movie.
there might be a little bit of connection
to what happened with Secret Invasion
just because of the Skrulls in general.
some of them are probably still working
on his saber space station.
but most of the Marvel's movie, I think,
is going to connect more to the Avengers
5 Kang Dynasty plot than to the Earth
based Captain America four Plot.
for the whole idea
is that they're explaining that
Captain Marvel
killed the Supreme Intelligence.
so da been in the Kree.
Think of her as quote
unquote the Annihilator,
which is a big a nihilist reference
I've done a couple videos on a nihilist
because it was a big guardians
of the Galaxy three deleted scene with the
Originally James
Gunn was going to have him
be the person to create Rocket,
but then completely changed his mind.
It made the high evolutionary instead
the analyst character is a huge fantastic
four character.
He's from the negative zone which is a big
location is fantastic for comics.
They also featured in the 2015 Fantastic
Four movie
maybe we'll see him in the MCU
at some point as an overarching villain
in the Annihilation wave.
there are a lot of references
to that storyline in the comics
during the Guardians
of the Galaxy trilogy, just because that's
where a lot of those characters
originally came from
she's mostly been increased girl space,
dealing with the Kree
and all the other planets.
Just trying to help random peoples
all over that part of the galaxy.
Really good example.
This is when Da Ben, played by Zoe
Ashton, who's actually the real life
wife of Tom Hiddleston, who plays Loki
also in the Marvel universe.
a lot more Marvel couples showing up.
she's the new leader of the free in
the absence of the supreme intelligence.
And the idea is that, Carol Danvers
killed the Supreme intelligence.
and that's what Da bin is talking about
when she says,
You took everything from us.
supposedly when the events of the movie
pick up, like years after the events
of the Captain Marvel movie,
the Kree people are doing terribly late.
Their race is in ruin.
Even though they were able to almost kill
off the skrulls they got rid of Skrulls.
That's why all the Skrulls came to Earth
after the five year time jump started
right after the snap, cleared up a bunch
of real estate for people to move in.
so even though they've been able
to pull that off up
to the beginning of Avengers
Infinity War, at some point things
just go really badly for their race in DA
Ben takes over leadership
and is looking for a way
to revitalize their race.
And she's using the second bangle
like Ms..
Marvel's other bangle that we kept
wondering about during the Ms..
Marvel series.
turns out they really are
saying they are the Kree Naga bands,
which basically turn thought into energy.
They're kind of like Green Lantern rings
in the Marvel Universe,
meaning that the blue hand in the temple
of the ten rings like big thing she Easter
egg actually belonged to a soldier
that was wearing that part of the bangle.
da. Ben is using her bangle
to actually open these portals.
And still the resources
from all these planets.
The Carol
Danvers says the places that we call home,
she's basically pulling a Galactus
sucking all the resources out of planets
to help the three
and it looks like one of the targets
is Prince John's planet here.
Aldana, who's being played by park.
So, June,
but like I said, the big concept
that they're teasing
during this movie is the incursions
becoming a bigger thing
because we're getting so much closer
to Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty in Avengers
six, Secret Wars where the multiverse
begins to collapse on itself.
Blame Deadpool
for some of that happening too.
We'll see a lot of that idea
during Deadpool three.
Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe
but it's Deadpool kills the Fox Marvel
Universe. there's a bunch of big stuff
happening this week.
We just found out about a cool
deleted scene from Spider-Man
across the Spider-Verse
with Tom Holland's Spider-Man.
I'll try to post that later tonight,
and I'll also try to do a one piece video
as soon as possible to.
lot of Big Ahsoka stuff happening too.
So click here for my brand
new Ahsoka Episode 4 trailer video
and click here for that Spider-Man
across the Spider-Verse
deleted scene with Tom Horn.
I'll update the link
as soon as I post that video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!